League of Legends pros trained for
countless hours to perfect their craft
and impress thousands of fans with their
plays and stage presence
I'm Lisa from the score eSports and in
honor of Valentine's Day we are counting
down our picks for the top 10 hottest
players right now in League of Legends
coming in at number 10
if slices jungler trashy he's charming
and well spoken with a killer smile and
baby blue eyes oh and if skill no
jungles don't hurt either and you can
see how the effect can see look are they
lucky that was beautiful
I trust just body slam strategy mostly
like girls that know our thing cuz it
was pretty a turn-off in the beginning
that you're playing video games all day
I sort of think this kind of thing is
kinda weird in a way but some of them
are pretty cool with it now and they
also support me coming in at number 9 is
Maurin a player who began his career
playing for SKT but then hopped over to
the LPL for a year now he's back in lck
on africa freaks to try to reclaim his
former world champion title barnes
confidence and seal on the risk is one
thing his wall is bone structure another
thing completely thank you everybody
I love you number eight is none other
than flame a guy whose skin is so
flawless I'm pretty sure I saw him in a
skincare commercial before with his envy
able complexion and the founder of the
flame horizon it's easy to see why he's
a fan favorite these damn cake goes down
the flame brother where did you go there
he is back for these teammates at
immortal they fought their way out of
the corner lupus that plays on a triple
sail another gonna go for here boy
Oh God look for the Quadra quandra Jill
proclaim in his first game of the ALCS
despite it being his first split in the
NA LCS akkadian is quickly establishing
himself at the contender to be the next
first flood king with sorry Angus he
earned a spot on our list for his hot
debut into the professional scene
akkadian showed up bigger than any of
them only jungler in the NA LCS app that
we've won to have 100% first blood
participation hearing the fans scream
when stuff happens and stuff is really
really fun so I've been having a great
time so far oh and I'm pretty sure he's
a regular at the gym Pauser takes the
sixth spot on our list not only is Han
sir one of the best top laners in any at
the moment he also has a winning smile
not to mention we've noticed that he's
been running around topless and TSM show
legends quite recently
well-played TSM Ward this who's going to
kick them over right into the team
tackle into the wall really pretty
beautiful here now some day just going
to ride of HP one more hit I'll do it
transit rain would I do enough damage it
was a girlö mini groan not going to be
enough been scare and gets out first
blood rehaan sir
the next player on our list was half of
the deal we fell in love with when they
played together in the EU and na LCS
currently Team Liquid jungler reignover
has won the MVP award in a 2016 na LCS
spring split while playing with
immortals and is still highly regarded
as one of the top junglers in the region
from his reliable and smart play on the
wrist to his adorable smile
reignover earns 5th place on our list
the reason I became pro gamer was also
like you to be loving playing games but
also like I just want to tell my mom
like she was having a lot of hard time
so Cara no using a target it doesn't
seem like TSM skewed on the target they
want kha'zix coasted that's going to be
rain over coming in at number 4 on our
list is York sin who we can only
describe as geek chic he's won multiple
MVP titles and is considered one of the
best mid laners in the world even
getting a shout out from the god himself
faker disposal
is Fiona Vito anyone ever since he came
over to na this Danish power house has
been the center of PSN and a player that
fans can rely on never mind his creepy
game play and stats tsm's beard sinister
sweetheart we'd all want as our
Valentine
okay we're down to the top three hottest
players taking the 3rd spot is kt
rolster top laner smeb he's considered
one of the greatest players in the scene
right now from his time on the 2 / rock
Tigers so now we're just playing a one
of Korea's super team fun fact did you
know that he also made history by being
the first top laner to get a pentakill
in acetate history step on a rampage
through the enemy tank oh but chaser
moving toward has he got you far the
interest yet crippled girl is that one
Raquel it's a cocktail it will be the
rivet Petra and says will lock up the
first head to kill up it's deepen mix
and his deep voice
adorable ass and jokingly cocky attitude
snubz easily comes in as number three on
our list number two on our list its
clg's top laner darshan doesn't even
matter dick city just came up that big
yes it does what a barn burner start
shot a few more eve he kisses it goes
out charming check well-spoken check
great facial hair check and it's not a
secret that we've got a great singing
voice if he wasn't a legal legend pro
he'd probably be a youtube stinging
sensation you should let me love you let
me be the one to give you everything you
want Andy and now the moment you've been
waiting for the number one spot
fanatics ad carry reckless takes first
place on our list it was a unanimous
vote amongst our team and it's pretty
easy to see why
the collectors with my testimony this ad
carry has stolen the hearts of fans
everywhere he's proven his talent on the
wrist
that's good we were ready to lay back a
big knock oven here come booty he's
already goin on the boys the triple kill
for setting up the kiddin to run away
Olie ploys and he never ever seems to
have a single hair out of place
and there you have it these were our
picks for the top 10 hottest players
right now in League of Legends
do you agree or disagree with our list
we want to hear why in the comments
below thank you so much for watching and
on behalf of everyone at the score
eSports have a happy Valentine's Day
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button